Elizabeth when we look at the bigger
picture it seems like Russia has been
making progress however gradual that may
be how would you say the the pace of the
war is changing
as you say Russia seems to have turned
the tide we all remember that the early
weeks where nothing much was going right
for Russia now the Russians seem to uh
well are clearly focusing their efforts
on on this strip of land here uh in in
the east of Ukraine around towns and
cities like Lyman and severo Donetsk but
we should also remember that as you
mentioned uh president zelenski has been
visiting which was previously a very
fought over city that is now safe for
him enough to safe enough for him to
visit as of course other western parts
of the country where the Russians have
retreated so now they the fighting is
very much here in this strip of land the
Russians say they have taken this town
of Lyman which seems very unimportant
until you consider that it has it's a
railroad Hub and it also has sits by a
major road and of course is also very
close to the city of severe which is the
last major population Center held by the
ukrainians in this strip of land here
right okay so we've reported on Russia's
blockade of course of the port city of
Odessa in the South how are world
leaders trying to address this because
of course it's it's not just the
blockade there it's the grain that is
stored there that is crucial as well
that's right and that's why the blockade
matters to every single one of us
because Ukrainian grain can't get out
and can't get to the rest of the world
and that's why a world leaders are
reported to be discussing some sort of
solution and that's that solution is
thought to be a naval escort Arrangement
so that ships can get out of those ports
in Ukraine and get through the Black Sea
down to
um to the exit of the Black Sea and into
international waters
the the question though is whether those
talks are progressing and how serious
they are and also if they were to be
successful where the shipping companies
and insurers would be willing to to sail
through these very dangerous Waters
under those conditions